المانيا اخذت معارك عديده مع رؤساء
امريكيين عده جاني كارتر ورونالدو بسببي
اعتمادها على الطاقه الروسيه والان بسبب
الصين تجدون نفسها في معركه جديده لكن انا
شغل زاره بكين لكن توقيت الزياره اقلق
واشنطن والحلفاء وبعدها اسابيع من فتره
ولايه ثالثه تاريخيه لتشيجن وحتى عندنا
شغل رفضا ان يرافقه فيها الرئيس الفرنسي
حسب رويترز
الحكومه الالمانيه تؤكد ان واشنطن هي اكثر
الحلفاء الغربيين انتقادا لها بسبب
الزياره لكن المصالح تتصالح اهو مصطلح
معروف وبتعبير حكومه برلين فهي تتبع
مسارها الخاص
الانتقاد هو الالماني الضمنيه الى الغربيه
يبدو ان له خلفيه بسبب ازمه الطاقه وزير
الاقتصاد اتهم واشنطن قبل فتره بمطالبه
برلين باسعالا خياليه للغاز لتعويضي وقت
الشحنات الروسيه لكن ربما يرغب الطرفان
بوضعه نهايه لهذا الاختلاف وهنا زياره
اخرى بل ان كان في برلين نعم اجتماع
مجموعه السبع لكن الكواليس قد تكون منيحه
العقده